oh ich habe eine miniatur her als alter
das ist geil das ist genau das was ich
brauche hallo ich meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft und ich bin
gehofft ich mal allein auf dem server
ich glaube ich bin alleine hier direkt
chocobos warum rufen
in der letzten folge war es so dass
einige leute meinten
hier sind kusche ränder fehler was das
war's das schon dass hier für komische
federrath ich ganz gesund wieder raus
nicht dass das jetzt an mir liegen dem
server ich weiß nicht ich würde ja mal
tippen auf dem server ja egal jedenfalls
mhh ich bin noch komische fehler
was soll das mit shader auch was wir
nicht noch weiter weg fliege hier geht
doch hier geht es eigentlich
es ist nur dahin nur hier sind so
komische ränder fehler verrückt hier
geht's auch nur da irgendwie na gut
vielleicht liegt das in meiner mob
fahren das kann er sein
in der letzten folge war es so dass
komme bei mir in der nähe war ich
versuche jetzt nochmal das ist ja
richtig eklig mit diesem komischen
fehlern hier mache jetzt mal ganz kurz
so ich weiß nicht wie genau das ist uns
mit ich muss man mit cap aufnehmen das
damit dass da ein bisschen erzählt weil
ich brauche auf jeden fall level um
meine verdammte rüstung hinzu
verzaubertes es einen teil verzaubert
naja jedenfalls in der letzten folge war
es so dass relativ viele leute meinten
von kraft foods geht es einfach aus dem
kampf in gombe da ist blablabla ja dass
ich bin allerdings nicht untergegangen
weil bekam soll
meine folge allgemein schon 22 minuten
lang baut ich komme sogar geschrieben
habe komme ich bin nicht in der stadt
bla bla bla bla bla
weil ich war er da zu dem zeitpunkt euch
dass ein text kann letztendlich auch zu
der zeit einfach mal ein bisschen rum
hier in der gegend
ich war ja extra unterwegs lexika
lizenzen zu suchen um ein bisschen
schafe zu finden und um leder und die
ganze scheiße nicht alt für die fifa
benötigt habe die ich ja auch nun habe
die sache ist allerdings die dass gold
anhalt kam als ich weg war aus der stadt
dann habe ich geschrieben habe brauche
ich gar nicht suchen ich bin ich in der
stadt und ich wenig in den kampf
gegangen weil ich meine fifa zu dem
zeitpunkt noch gar nicht fertig hatte so
was halt so dass ich dann in meine stadt
zurück gegangen haben die farmer gemacht
und die wahrheit kein bisschen
verzaubert und mein schwert hat halt
auch ersten nur noch beck 1 und so dass
es halt keine verzauberung im kampf ich
halt direkt gestorben das wäre halt plan
gewesen
deswegen kommt jetzt allerdings einige
da komme dann auf einmal irgendwie ich
hatte da meine kisten sortiert habe
gesagt okay ich werde jetzt meine folge
jetzt bin ich relativ weit fertig und
dann kamen kommen auf einmal drauf und
dann habe ich nämlich gesagt okay jetzt
endlich meine folge weil ich die
referenten wollte ich habe dann halt nur
ein flug zauberstab gehört und ich habe
das jetzt nicht irgendwie beendet nur
weil ich dir denn in dem in dem kampf
mit komme aus dem weg gehen wollte dass
ich musste das mehr oder weniger wenn
meine folge ich schon zu ende war und
weil es ja auch kein richtiger kampf da
grad zustande gewesen war
wenn du mich schon bevor ich gesagt
hätte ja ich bin jetzt fertig wenn der
mich da schon angegriffen hätte dann
hätte ich nicht einfach vom server
herunter gehen dürfen weil das ist
mittlerweile eine regel dass man da
irgendwie wenn man eineinhalb minuten
aus dem kampf draußen ist dann muss man
irgendwie noch drauf bleiben oder
irgendwie sowas das ist neuerdings in
aller regel die von uns dem regelwerk
hinzugefügt wurde nachdem das ein paar
sachen von tempel 1 nach dem besonders
die sehr schön ist übrigens nachdem da
so ein paar sachen passiert sind ort vw
halle verlor ihr blendend peters du bist
auch erstmal ins schwert so allah will
ich muss es einfach wirklich mal
verzaubern kann es echt fast noch gar
nichts
jedenfalls habe ich dann halt ein paar
leute beleidigt obwohl ich eigentlich so
oder so beenden wollte das war dann
alles so ein bisschen falsch sag ich mal
missverstanden haben uns dabei hat auch
schon gesagt weil als das dann die folge
bei ghom rauskam und irgendwie meinte
kommt dann irgendwie höhe camper oder
irgendwie sowas keine ahnung und die
sache war das nicht dass viele leute
echt zu herzen genommen und sind dann
einfach zu mir die videos gegangen wo
man einfach mal so schreibt einfach mal
drunter dass ein fixer penner ist und
dann haben wir halt nicht alle beleidigt
und bla bla bla bla bla
das war halt nicht so geil deswegen
werde ich euch ganz verbunden wenn das
sind place das ist natürlich irgendwie
schön aber irgendwie ist das auch nicht
so will nicht so schön
ich werde ganz verbunden wenn ihr das
unterlassen würde weil ich werde noch
mal mitkommen drüber reden auch dass das
ganze mal aufhören soll weil das halt
wirklich nicht meine absicht war da
irgendwie kampf aus dem weg zu gehen ich
musste halt so oder so meine folge
beenden
von daher das wollte mal ganz kurz eben
aufklären ich nehme jetzt auch immer
noch alleine auf ich habe keine pläne
mehr irgendwie die ich noch vorhaben
jetzt so speziell dass das einzige was
ich noch so richtig mir vorgenommen habe
ist jetzt einfach noch mehr herzen zu
bekommen also durch diese miniatur kacke
und so oder sind börse paris kommt die
treppe hoch kommt die treppe hoch ist
einfach dass ich mehr herzen kriege
durch diese miniatur kacke und so wenn
man kann sich also miniatur herzens
behälter machen dafür braucht man
allerdings zum miniatur herzen und so
was alles und byrd und es ist halt mega
schwer ranzukommen weil ich glaube ich
habe nicht mal irgendwelche miniatur
herzen unsere das ist halt so ein
bisschen doof dann komme ich dann halt
nicht so schnell an ihr könnt mir auch
immer so sachen schreiben die um die ich
mich dann kümmern soll
und es war so ein bisschen komisch dass
die letzte folge irgendwo 406 hatte
lastwagenverkehr warum und dann hat mir
das allerdings schon geschrieben dass
sie das leid wird uns das erst gesagt
hat das ist ja gar nicht so ab na ja gut
das ist abgehakt es wird jetzt langsam
wieder nacht
ich hoffe immer noch dass ich eine hexe
carl ist suche ich dann nach hause
porter nämlich mit meinen scale amor
helm wieder machen kann und ich laufe
jetzt einfach so lange bis ich direkt
auf einen zulauf und das auch schon ein
und jetzt noch eine frau sind richtig
viele irgendwie habe ich so das dumme
gefühl dass in schnee biom einfach viel
mehr ex ik lizenzen sind aber irgendwie
ist das halt doof bei nacht gehen wir
jetzt weiter zu suchen da hinten ist
wieder zum leuchten doppels werde ich
über sie ich verstehe dass die pilze
machen kloster das dachte so jetzt
verstehe ich es auch dann kommt glas
dann rast ist das da oben eine die sind
aber das sind länder existenz sie sind
also ähnlich ausgenutzt wie du es aber
wichtig dass dort ein bisschen erfahrung
ich brauche wirklich erfahrung ich weiß
dass es am besten durch ich muss ihn
noch mal in die hölle in der hölle sind
ich muss einfach unserem opfer langsam
ins laufen bringen da muss ich echt war
mit kev einfach aufnehmen oder ihr
schreibt mir einfach mal wieder wie die
dings funktioniert also gut ich habe
meine hexal ist glaube ich jetzt erstmal
acht touren als topteam habe ich sogar
schon wieder gemacht
ich könnte ja mal versuchen ich kam
einfach ganz frisch da oben
verpiss dich geht aber man das ist doch
legitim runter ich versuche einfach mal
ups
ich musste irgendwie hoch und den
hätte er schon weg
die kiste nicht dran was sollte ich eine
kiste was soll das
und ich komme dieser tiefe noch gar
nicht richtig gleich wenn er viel zu
schnell damit wohl stärker
da ist er
er ist tot kann ich jetzt an die kiste
jetzt kann ich daran und jetzt stürzt
alles ein
achten wir auf den tour als expedia.de
schaden
ich bin vergifte das man übrigens auch
mal die sonne ein schwert in die hand
nehmen und ich dachte mir es für richtig
krieg doch weitere duft duft duft diese
komischen geräusche aber ich kriege
keinen schaden dadurch mal oder fange
jetzt jetzt bricht auseinander
erich kriegt dadurch kein schaden majors
in der hand hält ist es hört sich zwar
so an habe ich bekomme kein schaden oha
wie weit der eingestürzt ist sagt esther
stiftung so ein bisschen ein aber okay
gut kennt man hier weit dann bist du
hier rumliegen bisschen erfahrung warum
habe ich jetzt wieder ist nur 21 auf der
unten sind europa ace asse skelette sind
nicht die ekelhafteste ob sie können
einfach runter schießen und tschüss
sowas liegen jetzt als noch so für alle
teams keine ahnung was hier geht alles
einsammeln
oh ich habe eine miniatur her als alter
das ist geil das ist genau das was ich
brauche bist echt wichtig was die kinder
alles rum
ich werde mal ein paar sachen die mir
wichtig sind weg so dass das motiv stone
ron slaymaker spinnen augen ein
feuerzeug manderscheider sein skelett
von ämtern und noch welche oder und
nichtbehinderte wenig muss auch mal
wissen was jetzt besser es ist mein
legia bogen besser oder ist mein
christel besser das ist auch so eine
sache die ich mich frage kommt man da
und markus klett durch süße so dass in
the book ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz meinen rucksack er ich hab ja
hier ist glück dass ich ein rucksack
besitzer packte einfach mal alle sachen
rein das ist aber richtig richtig gut
dass wir ein miniatur herz gefunden
haben und vier goldene äpfel das ist
auch mega gut
länderspiel geht auch noch fit ist echt
geil dass wir das miniatur herz haben da
freue ich mich echt ein bisschen weil
dann kann es auf jeden fall schon mal
einen extra herz machen vielleicht sogar
noch in dieser folge ich muss mal gucken
zuerst mal abstecken ob da oben auch
irgendwie erfahrungen ist
tschuldigung konnten es erst mal
mittwochs spinne ich habe irgendwie so
ich fühle mich mit meinem bogen viel
sicherer als mit einem doofen schwert
hier halte das für eine heftige sperrte
die gegend wie verzaubert
da kriegt auch schaden nicht die treffe
dies auch stark die starbucks von
spinnen diese heftig sind
ich kriege aber keinen schaden dadurch
weil ich ja mein tolles giants wort in
der hand halte hier darum ist so viel
erfahrung ich will zu der erfahrung sind
die sommer hier hochkommt ich darf das
wäre jeder war einfach mal ränder bock
schießen sich gegenseitig ab die
behinderten sich gegenseitig ab werk
erstmal was man diesen block h
die haben einfach diese heftige spinne
getötet die ganze skelette da unten sind
die doof
nicht weg dass so ein bisschen gerade
auf dass hier das hier überall so viele
dörfer spinnen und lasse spinnen war
ich hoffe der haube zwei sondern richtig
richtig viele spielen
so richtig böse monster und klassisch
bin ich kann spinnen echt nicht ab das
ist einfach wahr
warum existieren diese scheiß viecher
das ist richtig eklig wer braucht schon
warum soll ich dann skelett wir sind
dadurch nicht
tschuldigung hallo so macht jetzt kommt
ihr wieder eine spinne was hier drin das
ist was ich mit diesem neuen machen kann
das weiß ich auch noch nicht
ich bin da echt auf eure hilfe
angewiesen hallo werd ich bin kollegen
hier denkt mal so wenn ich dieses ganze
schadens gedöns hier höre dass ich mega
den schaden nehme aber es ist ich nehme
einfach nahezu gar keinen schaden
aber man hat trotzdem immer irgendwie
ein bisschen angst obwohl ich jetzt nur
ein halbes herz verlierer ist hab ich
ein herz verloren
das ist halt einfach das dass wir eine
relativ gute rüstung wir müssen die
rüstung zwar noch ein bisschen
verzaubern und die geht auch die ganze
zeit immer noch so ein bisschen kaputt
und ich musste noch an breaking
draufpackt und die ganze kette jetzt
will ich mal etwas wertvolles darin
macht das gerade nur wegen der
erfahrungen mit schwert in die hand
nehmen müssen halt echt ein bisschen
appartement finden eher ja du bist auch
kacke du auf ihr seid alle kacke hier ja
ich habe angst vor den habe ich doch
schon drei herzen verloren
wir sind schon auf das unterste etage
glaub ich war der einrüstung an
ich werde wieder spinnt ja ich bin das
auch nichts wertvolles drin geil nichts
wertvolles tier sind ein bisschen
erfahrung erfahrung ist immer gut aber
die erfahrung verschwindet hier nein
dort liegt auch noch erfahrung ich
brauche ich zu viel erfahrung wie ich
kriegen kann so das ist eigentlich eine
ganz gute taktik zu den box oben töten
dass du alles explodiert und dann also
jetzt erst mal nach hause porten hier
irgendwie wo habe ich denn hier habe ich
viele diamanten sind eigentlich nix
wertvoll ist mir irgendwie ist irgendwie
weiß nicht gold ist dunkles habe ich
immer noch ein bisschen angst gold ist
ganz gut
ich finds ja auch mal ganz cool wenn es
so richtig heftige post ag also so
richtig ekligen wieder mal richtig
richtig große spinne ich hasse zwei
spielen aber dass wenn tatsächlich
heftige bosse oder sonst sollen sondern
richtig richtig großen von nicht nur
diese komischen golems auf ihren top
dauern da oben das ist irgendwie weiß
nicht bisschen einfallslos so ich habe
jetzt keinen blog über mir aus schneidet
das heißt ich kann jetzt einfach mal
meinen tollen spiegel rucksack benutzen
neben den statt blau spiegel halte ihn
gedrückt und bin gleich wieder zu hause
hoffe ich ja und da sind immer noch die
komischen fehler gut du kommst als wir
rein
ich habe statt rot blau und gelb das
heißt ich kann theoretisch überall hin
einfach am besten wäre es einfach wenn
ich den von stadt roth wirklich irgendwo
abseits machen würde
dafür gleich ganze klasse und miniatur
herz wollte ich noch eben machen
mini batterie halt irgendwas mit hard
can ist da kanister the world airport
ein apfel und jemand und das habe ich
alles erst mal mit dabei das möchte ich
am liebsten noch in dieser folge hier
eben schaffen so jetzt habe ich an gigi
deppe empty kanister das sind vier eisen
die habe ich sogar mit dabei hallo
aluminium
das ist aluminium auch so wir gucken wie
a blue mini aluminium halloumi nummer
ist das aluminum auf englisch mal
abchecken habe ich das irgendwo ich muss
doch irgendwo aluminium haben oder ich
gebe
ok wo kriege ich den aluminium mehr
nein nein nein dafür bei euch diese
kacke da mit diesem online
ich glaube wir haben sogar seinen ofen
oder eine gemeinden dass wir so offen
dass sie soll angeblich unser toller
offen hier sein ist da irgendwas ich
kenne mich damit meine spiegel hat
darauf ist sie nicht irgendwo will sich
aluminium irgendwie irgendwo
ich kann mich hier mit ja echt gar nicht
aus
na gut dann schaffen wir das wohl mit
dem extra herz wohl doch nicht mehr
diese folge weil wir dann für diesen
komischen empty kerstan brauchen dafür
nominiert den rest kann ich aber schon
mal machen die kritik bauen
aber ich lege das jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz habe ich nicht auch hier noch zu
einer ja genau so eine kritik bauen und
das herz kann ich da auch schon mal rein
tun da
so eine kritik bot der stellen streichen
musste er immer seine kritik scheiße
knochen
wollte ich ihn hingelegt doch nicht ich
hab den irgendwie nicht weggeschmissen
ob er mich behindert
wie ich kacke ist der 9
meine kritik bauen ist weg
auch mano oder vor bestehen dann rein
gelegentlich durch den rhein gelegt habe
oder irgendwie sowas
das ist aber das erkennt man noch gar
nicht mit diesem komischer suchfunktion
hier
es ist komisch produkt da kommt der
knochen hin hat ja damals komischer
andere dinge und jetzt machen wir doch
ganz schnell in den letzten minuten
cathay dachte schon wer aus einer
anderen stadt wie eine lokale ok lass
mal nachher war bin ich gut bin ich bin
ich froh dass es ein käfer weil ich bin
echt zurzeit nur am vorbereiten für den
krieg sex ekel diamond obsidian und gold
mexiko deimer
statt drei hektar mexiko
diamond obsidian und bewusst dass gold
ich habe aber auch löcher noch so gollia
obsidian obsidian ich noch ein bisschen
nutzen ja nirgendwo obsidian möchte das
noch in dieser folge schaffen
obsidian nähe hier ist kein obsidian ich
hasse dieses suchen er ich hätte diesen
die qlogic bauen auch fast gar nicht
gefunden wir diese komischen sachen
einfach nur so richtig richtig wenig
aufblinken scheiße das kann man die
seite des trips ideal habe auch noch nie
im voraus planen scheiße ich will das
jetzt noch hinkriegen aber jetzt muss
ich wieder nach hinten hin fliegen
schnell schnell schnell schnell schnell
ich bin ich nicht mehr ziehen
ich muss sehen ich mache den nächsten
folgen einfach ein bisschen wo war diese
komische abbaustellen denn da muss man
sich macht ihn jetzt zufolge einfach ich
glaube ich brauche gar nicht so viel ich
glaube ich brauche einfach zwei stück
oder noch die nächste folge hat dann
zwei minuten gehört sagen dann sollte
das hat denke ich dran sein sondern mal
eins und nummer zwei so ganz schnell
ich mach 3 scheiße nein nein
dass man also diese kurzen fehler die
man dann unter stress hat so wenn hier
drunter als lava ist bin ich relativ am
arsch weil ich kann mit meiner komischen
befristung nicht in lava schwimmen
deswegen hoffe ich okay jetzt muss ich
einfach nur schnell wieder nach hause
ich bin gerade die mir lieb ist weil ich
ganz einfach nicht so viel über ziehen
will
so ich habe glaube ich jetzt alles dabei
gold auch jetzt muss erst mal diesen
komischen kaffee wieder machen man jetzt
bin ich hier wird war am ende so dass
und gold so als haben wieder den
kommissions kelheim hier und es muss
sich aber nicht beenden deswegen ist es
ganz gut dass erst angenommen habe ich
hätte alles anders bisschen bezogen wie
ich gehe auch schon vom server herunter
ich möchte nur sagen ich hoffe dass mit
der situation mit verstanden
ich hoffe ich hals gefallen dass die
bewertung da egal ob positiv oder
negativ und dann sehen uns beim nächsten
wieder